[Music]
every morning i would wake up and stay
in front of the mirror looking at myself
for hours and being like
should i go no i should not go they're
going to be talking about your skin
color and it doesn't not pretty you're
not pretty
my name is kudiya vip aka the modern
goddess i'm a model and i'm defined by
standards
i grew up in senegal and then i moved to
ferris when i was 15.
i was bullied a lot because of my skin
color and i stopped going to school
twice because of it they would call me
[ __ ] thought of the night
and all kinds of names i was kind of
ashamed of being dark
i think skin bleaching is a huge deal
especially in african countries
i have a lot of cousins that use skin
glitching products since i was around 13
12 they started telling me oh why don't
you use this why you want to be this
dark they feel like being light is
better than being dark skinned like dark
tint is just related as poor dirty when
you look at film open tvs or magazines
the main beauties down there that you're
going to see is light skins and i feel
like other skin type should be
represented
what i love about my skin is how it
connects me to everybody
when i go outside
everybody come to me to ask about where
i'm from there were a lot of people that
were that would appreciate it they would
be like your skin is so unique and
beautiful you should be a model
and between the negative and positive
comments there are more positive
comments
i get a lot of messages from a lot of
women saying that i inspire them a lot
not just dark skinned girls but a lot of
women with insecurities my favorite part
is inspiring the youngest one because i
feel like
when they grow up they can teach other
kids and
the view of beauty totally changed from
that
[Music]
you